yeah low welcome to this video near this
video would be the first of them little
but interesting I hope series on that
deals with a question that actually
arises pretty pretty often in practical
chess and this is how to win with black
if the opponent plays a very rock solid
opening and this is called the London
system in fact that it happens really
often that you play against this opening
especially in blitz blitz game rapid
games that is even more popular than in
tournament chess but you know in
tournament chess you get it rather often
what I'm talking about is setup in which
white sets up the pieces as follows
don't really take blacks move into
account so much Bishop f4 III Bishop d3
and very often in place even see 392 or
something like this it's essentially
this setup Bishop on f4 knight on f3 and
this three points here III d4 c3 that
signal this yeah this London system the
setup and this is of course employed
against all kinds of black setups what I
just put on the board is a Queen's
Gambit type of setup but of course it
displayed them in these kind of
positions where black spawn stays on d7
and GM adopt something like a Queen's
Indian setup it is plate 1 black played
g6 so against the Kings Indian very
often white even puts an h3 is a mix to
prepare this kind of flight square for
for the bishop and make some loot for
the King yeah you face this rather often
and what problem is that it it is
actually a pretty good opening for white
it's not very ambitious and not very
much an opening that puts poor
lots of pressure on us black but it is
very hard to crack obviously it is solid
it's very often something like like a
Slav defense with an extra tempo is
especially if black plays d5 and the
Slav is very solid so what this small
series which will comprise of three m3
parts will do is suggest some way to
play as black against that so that you
have some idea how to get a position
that you can also try to play for
witness black it's not like you can get
an advantage this is a very solid
opening for white but there are ways to
play to get some tension in the position
so three parts mean this video will be
about setups where black displayed d5
the second video will be about setups
with Bishop a former Black has played
oops
of course he six where black has played
a six and didn't move the D pawn so
probably something like this like E 6p6
like a Queen's Indian and the third
video will deal with King's Indian
Center I'm not quite sure in which order
make two and three but it's essentially
one one set up with with g6 one set up
with e six and one with d5 and we start
with d5 so the London system in this
fashion
um yeah white usually starts with the
move Knight f3 in fact there is some
very solid and good argument to be made
that Bishop f4 oops
you should therefore move to is the
better move here and in fact I'm pretty
sure that this is the case um I also
show you why but let's first start with
denied f3 on this I recommend this black
to play just Knight f6 which should fit
with most of Black's repertoire choices
in fact you also must take into account
that white of course can play a normal
Queen's Gambit so if your answer d4 with
d5 you want to play this the classical
Queen's Gambit or the Slav and in each
cases or you can take of course in each
case the knight on f6 is fine
another way could be if you intend to
play some some some this triangle setup
you don't like talking about this here
then probably you should should play
this and after this setup in a slow
fashion but okay this is a specific move
water you could also play play this but
this is different obviously because what
I recommend will in golf in developing
the bishop so not the six should in most
cases suit you just fine for your for
your be a repeater choice
yeah then you've got Bishop f4 yeah here
black has more than one good system and
I think one is particularly effective
and this is simply what you should play
and this is c5 black just pushes in the
center and yeah play some yeah like a
Queen's Gambit e who's making this break
himself and the problem is in a way that
any kind of taking on c5 isn't too great
for white as the bishop is not
particularly well placed in a Queens
gambit accepted scenario you can attack
it here this pawn and we'll get it back
and this Bishop is not particularly well
placed
so why they're pretty much all the time
answers with a pawn move supporting this
pawn and then ninety six and c3 note
that if white would would take you can
get the pawn back easily with this move
White has no way to cover this and in
fact this Bishop is not particularly
well placed for this structure
so wide and this is heavens all the time
wide we'll just play c3 because it's
just the the normal program move for the
London system yeah and here I'm very
important move this is Queen b6
instantly attacking this b2 pond which
is obviously a soft spot and white
structures the bishop is develop data
it's a pawn chain and why needs white
needs to take care of this pawn he
cannot yet sacrifice it in any way and
the usual way that people covered is
probably not even the best way Queen b3
is by far the most popular move but it's
questionable if this is really good to
be honest a pawn move like b3 is simply
bad because you weaken the dark square
cm by by some extent and the the further
setup is is really easy black just
develops the bishop we can go here or
also to to g5 if you like it's both both
fine
and let's say Bishop a5 I like that more
and then you just build the normal setup
here with e6 this Bishop is outside the
pawn chain and there's some kind of
symmetry in the center but like is has
got the more aggressive pawn on c5 he's
the one to determine when this will be
in exchange on d4 and these squares are
really problematic b3 is stupid mules in
this structures well I can't even think
of here instead of Bishop f5 also a g6
setup is not bad because this bishop
will also put some fresh on the diagonal
so oops I didn't want to take back all
the moves I'm sorry I need to put them
on again just hit the wrong button so we
were here and I just explained why B's
that b3 is not so great
other options I'm always lead to the
same thing could be 3 something that I
showed separately but
say twin Siwon is also a way to cover
this you can simply develop here and
continue with e6 and have a fine
development
you simply have as mentioned the more
aggressive pawn structure it's still
fairly solid for wipe that's and there's
no question but it's a position that you
can easily continue to play as black and
don't have any problems whatsoever
a long-term plan can be to play on the
Queen side of course you know it that
and this is important if white covers
from the side here Quincy to covering
this you have the need to move a Bishop
f5 available Bishop f5 or probably even
take first and then Bishop f5 that says
something like this so that white cannot
take on c5 and now you have just one
attempt over here because white cannot
take on f5 he takes b2 will pick up to
pick up the rook in the corner so this
is this isn't recommended for white
white plays Queen b3 your answer with c4
which was which is an important truth
now white um retreats usually which is
answered by Bishop f5 again you really
need to take note of this idea it's very
important because it winds your tempo as
white has nothing better to retreat and
then lie can play six or you can also
play h6 to make some which we'd square
if you like all night h5 is also
interesting immediately attacking this
Bishop so black is really fine um those
one tempos have some significance rather
often wide exchanges though this is
probably even worse as now white faces
this unpleasant idea of an advance of
the b-pawn let's say 92 D 2 and then b5
before it's really a problem let's say
here here and yeah why does struggling
really - - to get a decent game very
often it leads to a very quick disaster
let's say for example white castle's
then you can take and move like this
even yeah it's hard for for--why to do
anything at the night b1 you can go here
but in the long run this is just just a
problem this pawn also note Bishop f5 e
6 we should be 3b to these kind of
things it's just a weakness on c3 of
course b7 also it's on an open file and
so on but one cannot take it so this is
a very nice position if white exchanges
on b6 in fact this is some position
about black in practical place cause far
more than I think it was 70% of
something white has a disastrous score
him it's um it's really am really
miserable but this happens rather often
in practice I get this get this often
important this if white we need cover
this way I showed this before that here
in this kind of position let's say h3 I
just put the northernmost of the bottom
cancels should be 792 castles this kind
of stuff this is what what usually
happens and then you need to to be
patient and play on the Queen side there
can be a can be various ideas that can
be the idea place c4 at one point
especially if you can support with b5
the Queen is a bit silly here and
probably needs to be relocated one idea
could be for example to play something
like rook c8 and even drop the Queen
back to get the b-pawn into play so your
general ideas to play on the Queen side
trying to to make something happen there
note that white has no advantages way to
change the pawn structure
this is very important to note that if
you get rid of the arrows that white in
this structure it has no favorable way
to change it he cannot play if all this
is controlled multiple times he cannot
really play see form as this would
weaken the the d4 pawn and lead to a
pretty bad isolated pawn position taking
on c5 is also not particularly
attractive like giving up the center
like this but like having an extra pawn
in the center white can start some play
with before but it's nothing you should
be afraid of like has all pieces working
nicely on the Queen side and this means
white has no favourable pawn breaks
which generally in yam in essence means
if white doesn't have any favorable palm
breaks black must have one and he has he
can play as mentioned rook c8 Queen back
and then try c4 b5 or you can take on d4
and play b5 before and that's a minority
attack so there were them multiple ideas
for black it's still completely solid
for white you can play this kind of
maneuvers to exchange pieces but in
general this is a position which tends
to be yeah slightly more favorable for
black even compared to what white can do
in this position so don't expect you to
win with quick mating attacks this is
not possible
so this is my basic suggestion against
the London system where white plays
Bishop wave form in case black plays d5
and has got this diagonal open it's a
good idea as shown to act quickly
yourself with c5 96 Queen b6 and then we
should f5
there are various move orders that white
can try to work against this plan and
one move order which actually is better
than the one I showed before is to play
this quick Bishop f4 the idea is the
following if black now plays Knight f6
white can start with III
c 5 c 3 a 96 so it's very similar if
white would now play Knight f3 we would
get after Queen b6 the variation that I
just showed showed before but what can
also start with this move and this is
actually a good a good alternative the
idea is if black now plays Queen b6
which isn't bad really it can do that um
if right now response Queen b3 like
plays c4 just like show before then in
this position here Bishop f5 is just a
blunder white can take it yes now you
can can save the rook of course then
maybe something better even that's so
quickly Queen B - I am moving maybe this
move was even better also having this
idiom not instantly because the rock is
saying but it's better to get the Queen
back so it's just a piece basically
visual f5 blunders a piece and yeah okay
this possibility not working is it's a
setback for black it's not terrible but
I actually recommend to in this move
order here to not even play Queen b6
it's not really necessary instead you
can play various other moves a good
solid choice for example is especially
if you for example play the CARICOM
which is popular opening you can just
take if you like C takes D is bad for
white not like terrible but the knight
is simply not not well placed in an Slav
exchange like him just develop easily or
after this you just play Bishop f5 or
Bishop g4 and it's just like Eric on
exchange very solid for black
another possibility would be after 92 to
instantly play this move which also
could transpose two lines that we looked
at before a wide place now this then
there's again Queen b6 and it's pretty
much a transposition so on black has
multiple good ideas you can also play
play g6 if you like it's also also a
possibility the only thing that I really
don't like so much is here this Queen b6
ideas mentioned as Queen b3 is a good
answer because now with Bishop f5 not
possible instantly it's not so nice
black can prepare this with g6 but this
allows eform and this gets complicated
it's not terrible for black but rather
complicated if you like you can study
this stuff it's quite interesting okay
this is one move order issue here if
black plays Knight f6 however you can
try something else even you can also
play the immediate c5 which is some
which is interesting and this allows
some a couple of other options
especially now from white white can now
play em an interesting gambit this is a
form really am fun move the basic idea
is that if white black takes only four
white plays d5 and it's like an albuns
counter gambit with an extra tempo in
Bishop f4 yeah black plays Knight f6 em9
c3 in fact you don't need to take on e4
but I think it so it should you should
do that really and actually have this on
the board once and the tournament game
last yeah and I played the movie six
which is similar to the Albin swear also
play a three and yeah this is quite
interesting like Queen e2 is
the the normal move then and g6 castles
lon
it's quite quite interesting so you
don't need to worry in this position
that your opponent bores you to death
that's really a sharp opening quite
funny after Bishop afford to get such a
sharp position you only need to be aware
of that if you play the instance e5 that
ephors valid idea and it has been
discussed in books so it's not like
completely offbeat that people would
never know this however you can as
mention also start with this movement
then plays d5 it's um it's um a matter
of a muth orders what what kind of
things you would like to avoid and you
like to allow the immediate c5 is
different in this this regard that if
you look at this position c3 let's here
actually you could spare with this oops
with 9 f6 and play something else here
for example here Queen b6 which is yet a
different thing
the the knight is not out so let's say
Queen B 3 C 4 Queen c2 then this move as
is possible again at least technically
it's it's possible it's not completely
clear what can probably take this and
take d5 and so on so it's um it's a
different different kind of line
actually my recommendation for for
simple players to start with Knight f6
and then play see 5 it's it's easier to
do but if you know for example that your
your opponent plays this e4 things then
and you like to have this kind of fight
then you can also play c5 and simply
this is the only real um yeah let's say
a drawback is the one word it's not
terribly great for white but this is one
thing you need to be aware of you play
the immediate c5 yeah in fact this is
some pretty much all you need to know
about combating the London system if you
play d5 and this is one I always thought
so
one advantage of playing 1d five against
deform that the London here is pretty
much yeah it's very easy for black to to
play with with with the c5 set up
especially if white plays Knight f3
first which is still the most common
move rod and then c5 really is is
absolutely nothing for white can not
even hope for the slightest of
advantages and you still have some some
play going it's not a completely yeah
completely lame equality all right this
is the first part of this entire London
is serious and I'll do this the the yeah
the further episodes with ecigs and g6
pretty soon so check out my channel for
this for these two additional videos